I was wondering like what are some of
your favorite storylines that almost
happened but didn't and thinking back on
famous favorite storylines that almost
happened but did not yeah like you
changed your mind during that process
like I don't know that's that's hard to
say
there is one chapter that I actually
wrote I've talked about this before
it's a Tyrion chapter from Dance with
Dragons
and it's a great chapter I really liked
this chapter it's very kind of spooky
and Atmospheric and there's a lot of
wonderful visual imagery in it and
there's an amazing character you know
who appears for the first time in that
chapter and I loved that chapter and
then I realized that Tyrion had led me
into a swamp and that after this chapter
I didn't know what followed you know
where do where do I go from here I tried
to save that chapter during dance with
numerous ways I mean at first I just
wrote it as a chapter and then I said
okay maybe it'd be better if it was
broken up and pieces of it we'll put in
this chapter and then that chapter and
then this other chapter and no no it's
worse better together so I put it back
together maybe maybe the way to do it
it's a dream it didn't actually happen
it's very ambit Aryan had this dream but
this is really cool and I finally just
gave up and ripped it out and said no I
can never this is it this is on its own
terms as the perfect chapter but it
leads me into a morass that I can't get
out of so maybe someday when I finish
the whole thing where I'm long dead my
heirs will publish the loss Tyrion
trapper
I don't know okay so you mentioned a
while ago that some of your characters
who created with some irony so I was
wondering what was your inspiration
behind the character of Davos Seaworth
because he seems to have a lot of
qualities of your typical hero like he's
you know strong morally just and
righteous but with a definite difference
in the fact that he's sort of at the end
of his life but his adventure is sort of
beginning well yeah you know some people
might say the same is true of me I don't
know where the particular inspiration
came from Davos you know I wanted to I
needed a point of view into the Stannis
camp in the war of the five kings I
needed a point of view there I started
out with his maester of course but then
he dies in the end of prologue so he
couldn't be a long one caring character
and Davos seemed an interesting way I
didn't want to make Stannis himself a
viewpoint character I wanted something
external to that but is Thomas is a very
complex character and a great character
I didn't want to give you his thought
processes just his words and actions hi
earlier you're talking about names and
mentioned yet note field I was just
wondering if you did have a child what
would you name him or her if I did have
a child what would I name him or her
well I don't know probably not Daenerys
it's too hard to spell I ardently enough
people do name their children after my
characters now and then they send me the
baby pictures and they email so there
there is an entire generation of
Daenerys Azari a--'s and the occasional
Cersei coming up
I think there's gonna be a lot of
kindergarten teachers are gonna be
cursing my name when these Daenerys is
with the AE and the Y's will hit
kindergarten at the same time and I
don't know what that little girl named
Cersei is gonna what the mother is gonna
say when she says mommy who's this
Cersei that I'm named after but there
you go
thanks for all the inspiration George I
really appreciate it I've one of those
crazy parents that named their daughter
The Hound so so appreciate that one of
my favorite parts of the just experience
in the books was what I called the part
which was what I used to call the red
wedding before it was the red wedding
because I'd have to tell people read
these books and then tell me when you
get to the part and then I would get
that call what's your do you have any
really good story what was your best
reaction to that part of the novel I can
only imagine someone came in and beat
you no no one beat me I did get of
course you have to remember that the
book came out like ten years before the
TV show so I already knew reaction when
we got to it on the TV show and all
these people videotaping their friends
as they watched it Ben and seeing the
reaction was no surprise with me I got
the emails a decade earlier and some of
them said things like oh I was so mad I
threw the book across the room and
smashed it up and all that and then a
week later I had to go out and buy
another coffee I like that
have us good double my royalties that
was cool
maybe the most amazing thing about the
whole thing was was the reaction to the
TV show seeing where people actually
videotapes they knew their friends and
relatives and loved ones would be really
upset so they put a video camera on
evidence shared your reactions on
YouTube I don't I don't know if anything
like that had ever happened before it
certainly didn't anticipate that hello
mr. Martin is a writer of a reader both
the Song of Ice and Fire trilogy and
some of the thousand universe world
there's plenty of themes there's mostly
an anti-war theme there's an anti
primogeniture theme what would you like
readers take away from the words and the
Song of Ice and Fire and do you think
that the show walkers will take away the
same thing yeah I don't really think in
those terms about you know this is gonna
be the theme of this book I mean books
contain many many aspects of life and
and love and the world and politics and
you're it's all grist for the mill and
you're all discussing it and especially
when you have multiple viewpoints you
have people looking at the world that is
the same in different ways and having
different viewpoints and you give them
each hopefully you're as honest as you
can to how that character would look at
these issues and they may not even agree
with each other
there are certainly messages there or I
don't know themes that you can ponder
and think about yet but nothing that can
be stated in a sentence if I could
stated in the senses I would state it in
a sentence and I wouldn't need to write
these hundreds of very very big lengthy
books where lots of words no really
really quick um one there's a missing
Clegane sister she hasn't shown up and
I'm wondering if that characters shown
back up in the story at some point and
then quickly as well the the red comet
that's going around the Sun you stick to
science a lot so it seems like it's gone
behind the Sun and are we going to see
its return trip
well I won't comment on future events
but I had fun with the red comet because
that was one of the usual you know let's
show portentous sign that every
character interprets differently in
their own favor so I thought nobody else
had done that quite before so I hadn't
been doing it
hi there I love your history's a mom so
had a history based question I was
curious if Bloodraven took dark sister
with him to the wall did Bloodraven take
dark sister with him to the wall his
sword dark sister yes he did yes thank
you so much yes I have rather of a
hopefully a fun question for you I have
in my hands here it's an internet meme
and I hope you're familiar with these
but it's a big picture of your face and
it says I don't always kill characters
but when I do they're your favorite I'm
actually really hoping that you'll sign
this for me later but do you have and
John this goes for YouTube do you do you
have a favorite internet meme of
yourself that you just saw it and you
just laughed I I can't say I have a
favorite meme no I'm you know I'm really
really old eyed this internet thing is
beyond me I I still try messages to the
legs of Ravens and send them off
hopefully they get somewhere so I don't
have a meme I'm not at that level but I
would say that there's a cover I did for
Frederick Poole's gateway Random House
right around 2005 and this is before you
know we have social media and somebody
brought to my attention about a year ago
that there was a there's a set of New
Age there's like a network of New Age
sites that have taken that image and
have almost created like a little quasi
religion around this image and what it
means and what it means to all these
thousands of New Age I don't know what
they are
physical followers and I check in on
that periodically and every once in a
while I feel like typing something in
and just that not I'm not that mean but
yeah there's you should do it but yeah
that's that's the closest I've come to
that